si vous vous polarisez sur l'âge de
départ et vous apportez vous approchez
la question dans le mauvais sens et on
aura une grande partie des députés de la
majorité même qui ne pourront pas suivre
cette sortie à 65 ans si à côté il n'y a
pas tout encore plus de justice et qui
donne un message clair au petites
carrière aux gens qui ont commencé tôt
qui se sentent aujourd'hui défavorisés
et victimes de cette approche à 65 ans à
la fin l'été François il avait été
question de faire la réforme en octobre
François Bayrou avait pesé tout son
poids y compris médiatiquement pour dire
il faut pas la faire là ça serait perçu
comme brutal il faut prendre le temps
parce qu'on aurait fait la réforme de la
retraite au mois de novembre et décembre
je sais pas socialement avec les
questions qui se posent aujourd'hui
comment ce serait passé
au même point qu'il y a trois mois en
janvier au moment où l'inflation va être
va être encore plus importante
l'augmentation des prix d'électricité du
gaz à 15% je parle même pas
d'éventuelles coupures d'électricité
donc c'est enfin franchement on est dans
la même situation janvier soit un chemin
de rose je comprends le bénéfice
politique de vouloir imposer une réforme
un peu en force par un 49-3 etc je
trouve que c'est pas la bonne méthode
parce que une récompense y compris en
janvier ce serait un problème pour vous
si c'était le 49-3 mais oui ce sera un
problème bien évidemment puisque une
réforme des retraites qui concerne tout
le monde doit être accepté par le plus
grand nombre donc il faut un processus
pédagogique de discussion de
concertation qui associe un maximum de
Français qui apporte qui qui donc
convaincre pour parler normalement non
et les Français en particulier moi je
suis
18 ans au Parlement au Parlement la
France insoumise votera pas pour cette
réforme bien évidemment mais je pense
qu'il faut et vous avez commencé à le
dire un processus pédagogique qui
explique le bien-fondé de cette réforme
à quoi ça sert de travailler plus ça
sert pas à pénaliser les plus petites
retraites et c'est ça qu'il faut
expliquer sinon vous aurez une grande
partie des gens qui seront opposés à
cette réforme même si elle est bénéfique
infinie pour comprendre vous vous êtes
député la majorité mais pas Renaissance
s'il y avait ce texte avec 65 ans dedans
vous n'êtes pas certain de le voter NON
je suis pas certain en l'état non ça
dépend par rapport à ce qui a en face en
termes de justice sociale la retraite
que l'on avait votée en première lecture
dans la précédente des statuts qui
viennent de retraite par point est une
réforme juste elle a été vilipendée par
LFI les personnes de syndicats qui
voulaient profiter des avantages acquis
notamment du régime spéciaux mais la
réforme elle était juste cette réforme
là elle n'apparaît pas si on est
uniquement sur l'âge de la
par la retraite et n'apparaît pas comme
juste et moi je me bats pour une réforme
de retraite juste et à ce stade là elle
n'est pas juste et je ne suis pas le
seul